nós passamos grande parte dos nossos
dias é movimentar diz de um lado para o
outro
no local outro fazemos uma forma
praticamente automática
mas para isso contamos com a informação
dos nossos sentidos revisão é
provavelmente ela que nos fornece mais
informação útil e que nos proporciona
movimentar de forma segura
então quem são os outros porque porque a
primeira vez que utilizei a palavra e
visuais foi logo corrigido pelos nossos
colaboradores que é um sexo
tanto eu vou utilizar a palavra sexo e
pessoas cegas não quer dizer que isto
seja partilhado por todos nós
é seguramente por aqueles que colaboram
connosco esta foi a primeira coisa que
eu aprendi consegue aprendi muita coisa
muito mais que casa que elas aprenderam
comigo sem dúvida efetivamente estas
tarefas básicas são extremamente
difíceis
é por isso que o grande objetivo deste
projeto é a tecnologia que permita
aumentar a autonomia a integrar na
sociedade a viver uma vida mais
confortável
utilizamos uma aplicação móvel
dispositivo móvel legal eletrônica um
módulo fiscal um computador sistema de
informação geográfica
outra tecnologia que possa ser o teu
questão é então o cego vai ter com toda
essa tecnologia tem aqui um problema
muito maior do que o caso provavelmente
este é sem dúvida um grande desafio nos
últimos anos
olhar uma interface que permitem uma
interação dessas pessoas com a
tecnologia de uma forma mais
transparente possível
certamente uma boa solução tecnológica é
quando ela é transparente quando essa
tecnologia nos faz no estado
desenvolvemos uma interface por voz
mais uma coisa que aprendemos o ao sida
que é uma resposta foi duplamente sei
como vamos resolver esse problema a
tecnológica fazer uma delas é o uso de
roteadores condição assim por exemplo
não vamos privada pessoa cega da ouvida
o ambiente que o rodeia como é que
consegue interagir com a cena thrash dom
joystick desenhado com as contribuições
dos nossos colaboradores
existe também ainda a possibilidade da
vibração
não ponho na venda efetivamente
utilizando a tecnologia disponível no
mercado
desenvolvemos protótipos e tecnologia
específica para este fim
o local essencialmente no dispositivo
móvel
podemos também ocorrerá a qual sempre
que exista uma uma ligação à internet
disponível
particularmente para o módulo
processamento de imagem que quer maior
poder de cálculo e é bem legal a bengala
foi também uma grande iniciativa que nós
tivemos qual a partida que foi pensar
vamos libertar o cego legal
completamente errado
em minha opinião
seguem se sente muito confortável
utilizadas em gala e sem seguro para se
deslocar tanto é ideia é exatamente
transformaram em gala tradicional que o
cego utiliza uma forma natural e
transformá la numa bengala eletrônica
nem gala ativa ele possa fornecer a
informação útil é adicional àquela que
ela já consegue correr em aula
tradicional
este é um primeiro protótipo está a
avaliar anos atrás num dia mundial da
seguridade
este é um dos últimos protótipos já com
o joystick integrado e que permite à
pessoa séria interagir com a aplicação
móvel
a informação do ambiente interage com
evelyn gala
este é o módulo da visão também um dos
primeiros protótipos que usava um
sistema de visão estéreo de grandes
dimensões muito com grau de
sociabilidade muito baixo no feito o
utilizador
atualmente a divisão ou neste caso
particular é quadro na haste dos óculos
normais e permita a aquisição de imagens
o envio dessa nova e também podemos
realizar duas tarefas distintas a
primeira é o reconhecimento dos objetos
do dia a dia pode realizar tarefas
simples como por exemplo ler um texto
previamente treinados para conhecer um
conjunto de objectos
e daí permitirá essa informação segunda
fundo o modo de visão
a segunda tarefa é fazer o
reconhecimento
num ambiente um espaço no exterior ou no
interior
o sistema tira automaticamente
características da infraestrutura e
quando volta a passar mesmo local
consegue localizar o utilizador e da
informação tem disponível uma forma
grosseira o sistema vai informar os
objetos e quais existem naquela
obviamente que novos objetos podem ser
adicionados nesse caso o o organizador
móvel não os conhece e portanto vai
disputar um evento para que seja
assinado esse objeto mais tarde
[Música]
o que vai mudar de orientação opções de
ensino alterar nível do talho da
inflação
sua sala de aula e quiser ser tristes
acho com a porta de vidro de entrada do
edifício
neste local encontrou um banco chegou ao
ponto diz roriz do edifício através de
uma fatores caldas
com a entrada da secretaria
[Música]
sua proximidade com dois pontos em treze
casa vai influir numa quatro metros à
sua direita casa algumas polina atingir
dentro da china
[Música]
antigamente esse sistema é integra toda
esta tecnologia e permite que o
utilizador funciona com ela de uma forma
um transparente
a tecnologia utiliza todos os sinais
disponíveis para localizar prender o
dono terminado o local e foi messi
fornece informação do contexto o
utilizador é também pode utilizar estes
componentes de forma independente
este é um novo protótipo de eletrônica e
um conjunto
o dispositivo móvel é um protótipo ainda
grandes dimensões não é o utilizava a
ser testado em laboratório uma boa
solução será obviamente dimensionado o
sistema no qual público do conceito das
e por exemplo o nosso objetivo que possa
enviar uma informação a um semáforo
próximo ao local
é também objetivo estender a outros
públicos como por exemplo turistas para
que esta infraestrutura se torna
sustentável e possa ser instalada no
maior número de locais possível
o objetivo final é sem dúvida a criação
de um produto possa ser disponibilizado
[Aplausos]